the first door was the easy bit the
suspect's flat upstairs was harder work
[Music]
but they kept their visit a surprise and
found their target in bed asleep
investigators described him as a
criminal broker of dodgy passports the
middleman between a crime gang who
supply them and fugitives who need them
but these are genuine passports in the
name of an individual
chosen because he looks like the
fugitive but using the fugitives
photograph
the passports are thought to have been
used around the world by suspects on the
run
they include cannabis smuggler jamie
acorte arrested in spain
gun runner richard birdette held in
holland and alleged cocaine trafficker
michael moogan extradited from dubai
if a criminal goes and steals a passport
or buys a stolen password they've always
got that concern that it's been reported
and every time they go through a pass
passport check or gate
they're taking a risk
this reduces the risk considerably
because it is a genuine item it should
get them through no problems at all
this suspect was said to have links with
one of the uk's most notorious crime
groups
this is part of a big operation there
are raids across the uk more than 250
officers are involved
24 suspects were arrested for a variety
of crimes including making and receiving
false passports and perverting the
course of justice
martin brunt sky news south london